dames et messieurs les sénateurs j'ai
été un bout que les gars honoré d'être
choisi parmi les personnalités qui
seront ont été ou seront entendus par
votre mission d'information en forme
d'un commission d' enquête au sein de
votre commission des lois et j'ai
volontiers naturellement et ferrer à
votre invitation
d'autant plus qu' elle ne souffre aucune
possibilité d'être contredite so lu ment
et donc vendable et le défenseur des
droits pourrait sauver le dernier à nier
effectivement cette prérogative des
commissions d'enquêté ce que je vais
vous dire naturellement est un peu je le
pense
d'une nature différente et beaucoup même
nature différente de ce que vous avez
entendu jusqu'à maintenant dans la
mesure où les personnes et qui avons été
entendus par votre commission denquête
sont des acteurs directs ou indirects
des faits sur lesquels vous enquêtez en
amont ou en aval pour ce qui me concerne
et vous venez de le dire monsieur le
président de la commission ce que je
peux vous apporter
c'est un éclairage sur une notion n'est
il n'y a pas si longtemps dans notre
pays
la fin des années 90 la déontologie de
la sécurité et sur les moyens que le
défenseur des droits qui en est
aujourd'hui
depuis la réforme constitutionnelle de
2008 et la loi organique de 2011 chargée
peut vous apporter pour en quelque sorte
vous instruire sur ce sujet bien que à
travers vous savez les très nombreuses
rencontres que nous avons souvent eu
entre la commission des lois et le
défenseur des droits vous ayez déjà sur
beaucoup de ses sujets beaucoup de
notions encore récemment lors de la
mission que vous avez effectués sur ce
que j'appellerais le moral des forces de
police et dont le le rapporteur était
monsieur grosdidier
l'article 4 de la loi organique du 29
mars 2011 confie parmi les cinq missions
qui sont les siennes au défenseur des
droits la mission de veiller au respect
de la déontologie par les personnes
exerçant une activité de sécurité sur le
territoire de la république
ce contrôle concerne et s'applique
policiers nationaux militaires de la
gendarmerie policiers municipaux agents
de l'administration pénitentiaire et
douaniers agents de surveillance des
transports en commun dont vous savez que
je fais une parenthèse du fait des lois
récentes notamment de la loi qui l'a
voulu il ya deux ans ils ont aujourd'hui
des prérogatives qui les rapproche
beaucoup des forces de police
gendarmerie les agents de sécurité
privés surveillance cardinal service
d'ordre privé les enquêteurs privés
aussi la peur et les détectives dans le
cadre de cette mission de veille du
respect de la déontologie par les forces
sécurité le défenseur des droits traite
des réclamations individuelles
l'année dernière elles se sont montées
dans ce domaine à 900 mène des
réflexions sur des sujets d'intérêt
général par exemple la doctrine du
maintien de l'ordre
l' usage des armes de force
intermédiaire
elle met en place des actions de
sensibilisation notamment par les
formations que nous dispensons dans les
écoles de police de gendarmerie ou de
l'administration pénitentiaire je rend
naturellement dans ce domaine des avis
au parlement sur les projets de loi
justement sur la loi savary dont je
parlais il ya un instant ou en matière
de sécurité publique nous avons beaucoup
travaillé avec votre commission pendant
toute la période de l'état d'urgence sur
les lois destinées à lutter contre le
terrorisme ou sur la loi par exemple qui
a modifié les termes de la légitime
défense pour les policiers
nous réalisons aussi des missions
d'observation et justement je vais en
parler à l'occasion par exemple de
démantèlement de camps migrants à calais
à paris ou d'autres circonstances dans
lesquelles une observation indépendante
est utile en 2010 est donc nous avons
reçu 1228 saisine dans le domaine de la
déontologie de la sécurité
j'ai donné neuf cents par erreur je me
référer à 2016 1228 saisine en 2017 dans
ce domaine de la déontologie de sécurité
dans le cadre des enquêtes qu'il a fait
sur les réclamations individuelles
le défenseur des droits a la possibilité
de demander la communication de pièces
administratives ou judiciaires
le secret de l'enquêté ou de
l'instruction ne peut être opposé aux
défenseurs les pièces couvertes par le
secret médical ou par le secret
professionnel entre un avocat et son
client lui sont également accessibles
si la personne concernée lui en donne
l'autorisation il peut d'autre part
effectué des vérifications sur place
il peut procéder à l'audition des
réclamants des témoins des mises en
cause qui peuvent se faire assister
naturellement de la personne
de leur choix dès lors qu'une enquête
judiciaire est en cours aucune
juridiction est saisie sur les mêmes
faits comme c'est le cas dans la
présente affaire
le défenseur des droits a l'obligation
de solliciter l'accord de l'autorité
judiciaire puis souvent c'est le parquet
avant de mettre en oeuvre ses pouvoirs
d'investigation tous les éléments réunis
au cours des investigations témoignage
pour administratif éléments de l'enquète
judiciaire certificats médicaux vidéos
sont présentées et débattues
contradictoirement au cours des
auditions
puis par écrit dans une note
récapitulatif qui est adressé aux mises
en cause et auquel celui-ci ou celle-ci
peut doit répondre avant que nous
prenions une décision
l'anc est mené aboutit donc à une
décision écrite qui peut en cas de
manquements avérés être assorti de
recommandations visant à prévenir le
renouvellement est pourtant sur la
nécessité d'engager des poursuites
disciplinaires à l'encontre de l'agent
mise en cause nous les demandes ont misé
l'intérieur ou menis de la défense par
exemple au ministre de la justice peut
emporter la modification de textes
législatifs ou réglementaires ou un
changement des pratiques parmi les dix
demande de poursuites disciplinaires que
j'ai formulées en 2017
trois paires je le souligne moins de 10%
des cas qui me sont présentés entraîne
de ma part une déclaration de manquement
c'est à dire que dans plus de 90% des
cas qui me sont présentés la demande du
réclamant et soit injustifiée soit il
est impossible de se faire une
détermination je le souligne parce que
nous ne sommes pas là comme une sorte
de surveillant général pour la police
donc parmi les dix demande de poursuites
disciplinaires formulaire 2017
trois ont mis en cause des comportements
violents en cours d'opérations de
maintien de l'ordre
l'une s'était l'utilisation d'un lanceur
de balles de défense 40 46 de manière
dissuasive décision 2010 est de 177
l'autre des violences commises à
l'encontre de manifestants à paris
2010cette 320 et la troisième des
violences commises à l'encontre de
manifestants à paris également 2010 7
c'est donc monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs rapporteur fort de
son expérience de ses constats et de sa
connaissance des règles qui régissent le
comportement professionnel des membres
des forces de sécurité que le défenseur
des droits s'efforcera de contribuer à
la mission de contrôle qu'exerce en ce
moment la représentation nationale en
l'occurrence je suis en mesure de vous
apporter un éclairage sur le rôle des
policiers nationaux concernant la
présence d'observateurs extérieurs au
sein d'une manifestation leur
encadrement
les limites de leurs prérogatives les
signes d'un style distinctif dons qui
peuvent être porteurs et d'autre part
vous faire part de réflexion générale
dès lors que je ne suis pas saisi sur la
réaction des policiers lorsque les
observateurs prennent une part active à
une opération de maintien de l'ordre et
sur les suites à donner sur un usage de
la force susceptible d'être qualifié
selon la déontologie de la sécurité de
disproportionnée il ya aussi une
question que je qualifierais dan ex mais
je veux la mentionner qu'en est-il de
l'éventuelle compétences du défenseur
des droits
concernant monsieur benalla dès lors
qu'il est habilité à exercer des
activités de sécurité privée par le
cnaps le centre national les activités
mais qu'il mais qu'il conviendrait de
connaître son rôle et ses missions
exactes pour déterminer si les
hertz à titre principal une activité de
sécurité première série de d'observation
le président le cadre général de la
présence d'observateurs accompagnant les
forces de l'ordre
je ferai d'abord mention de notre
expérience de l'expérience du défenseur
et beaufort par gevo créer les
difficultés qui sont posés par la sphère
dont vous êtes saisis sur ce sujet c'est
à dire la présence d'un observateur
accompagnant les forces de l'ordre la
présente affaire pose la question du
cadre juridique prévoyant la présence
d'observateurs accompagnant les forces
de l'ordre
à notre connaissance ce cadre n'est pas
formalisé ni par des notes ni par des
instructions
donc c'est dans ce cadre en toutes
sortes inexistant que je vais m'exprimer
l'expérience du défenseur des droits en
tant qu'observateur était certaine bien
que non formalisés la présence
d'observateurs accompagnant les forces
de l'ordre est possible et c'est ainsi
qu'à ma demande en lien avec le ministre
de l'intérieur et préfet de police de
paris
plusieurs de mes agents ont été
observateur au cours d'opérations de
maintien de l'ordre
à l'invitation du ministre de
l'intérieur lui-même chez cazenove à
calais à l'occasion du démantèlement du
camp de la lande en octobre 2016 après
avoir informé le préfet de police à
l'occasion du démantèlement du camp de
migrants de stalingrad à paris en
novembre 2016 sur invitation du préfet
de police lors du défilé du 14 juillet
2017 et très récemment
après j'en ai informé le préfet de
police à l'occasion de l'évacuation du
campement de migrants de la villette le
30 mai 2018
chacune de ces missions d'observation a
été préparé en toute transparence avec
la collaboration des autorités de police
par le biais de contacts téléphoniques
puis formalisé par des échanges de mails
et de courrier sur chacune de ces
opérations les agents du défenseur des
droits avait pour unique mission
d'observer le travail des forces de
l'ordre et la prise en charge des
personnes et des migrants et avaient
pour instruction de ne pas intervenir
dans les opérations en cours
il disposait d'un numéro de téléphone
leur permettant de se mettre rapidement
en contact avec un policier référent
joignable en cas de difficulté il était
présent à la fois sur le terrain avec
les policiers les gendarmes et au centre
d'information et de commandement pour
avoir une vision plus globale du
déroulement des opérations
ils ont également pour consigne de
présenter systématiquement leur statut
et le but de leur présence lorsqu'il
entre en contact avec une personne
quelle que soit sa qualité et sont
aisément identifiables par le port d'un
brassard bleus qu'il porte sur le bras
et qui est sur lequel est inscrit
défenseur des droits aussi le droit ça
reporte les observateurs du défenseur
des droits lorsque ils font des
observations
ça n'a l'air de rien mais ça a créé dit
naturellement la mission qu'ils
effectuent
ils sont donc aisément identifiables par
le porte ce brasseur
à l'issue de ces opérations
d'observation qui se sont toujours
déroulées dans de bonnes conditions y
compris je le dis dans les circonstances
les plus difficiles et notamment vous en
souvenez tous quand le camp de la lande
à calais a été évalué en octobre 2016 à
la suite ces opérations se sont toujours
déroulées correctement les agents de
défenseur des droits ont
systématiquement rédiger des rapports
mentionnant l'offre constat voilà
monsieur précédente
l'expérience vécue de l'observation par
le défenseur des droits
les difficultés posées par la présente
affaire
quant à l'observateur son statut sa
conduite il est difficile de déterminer
avec certitude
la procédure à suivre pour solliciter et
obtenir une habilitation pour être
observateur
je vous ai dit ce que nous faisions nous
dans le cadre de notre mission mais ça
ne répond à aucune je dirais règles
préétablies deuxièmement il est
difficile de déterminer la personne qui
a autorité pour délivrer une
habilitation de déterminer le but de la
présence d'observateurs en général et en
l'espèce au regard de leurs fonctions à
l'elysée de déterminer quels sont les
instructions transmises aux observateurs
sur leurs prérogatives
leur marge de liberté de déterminer les
signes devant être portée par les
observateurs susceptibles de les
identifier sans les confondre avec des
membres des forces de l'ordre qu'ils ne
sont pas les mesures de sécurité à
prendre pour éviter qu observateur
soient mis en danger et à ce titre le
port d'un casque de policiers par un
seul des observateurs alors que ni le
second observateurs ni le référent
n'emporte peut interroger le rôle du
policier référent qui dans la présente
affaire accompagner les deux
observateurs l'obligation de rédiger des
rapports par les observateurs et leur
référent à l'issue de l'observation
l'organisation de réunions de
préparation et de comptes-rendus
permettant d'organiser l'observation
dans les meilleures conditions et de
faire un retour d'expérience sur les
constats et les éventuelles difficultés
rencontrées sur tous ces points il n'y a
pas en réalité de règles il existe
probablement d habitude il existe des
façons de faire et je ne les met pas en
cause mais je pense que elles n'ont pas
naturellement la certitude que peuvent
comporter
les règlements et c'est pourquoi je
ferais monsieur le président mais une
recommandation dans votre commission
c'est celle de formaliser un cadre
juridique sur la présence d'observateurs
accompagnant les forces de l'ordre et
ses cadres juridiques devraient
notamment concerné la situation des
référents aussi ce qui devrait permettre
à l'avenir de résoudre certaines des
difficultés soulevées par la présente
affaire
maintenant mes observations sur les
faits qui se sont produits le 1er mai
2018 et qui sont à l'origine de la
mission d'information dont à laquelle je
suis entendue dans ce type de situation
je peux dire ce que mes services
furet il mènerait une instruction
contradictoire en demandant
communication des différents rapports
qui ont été rédigés les enregistrements
vidéo conserver et en procédant aux
auditions des protagonistes
mais dès lors que je ne suis pas saisi
de cette situation mes observations
seront donc formulé sous forme
d'interrogation et non de constats sur
le déroulement des faits que par
définition je n'ai pas pu faire
autrement dit qu aurait fait le
défenseur des droits s'ils avaient été
saisis en mettant en oeuvre les méthodes
d'instruction qu'il utilise couramment
afin d'accomplir sa mission de contrôle
de la déontologie de la sécurité
je vais d'abord parlé de l'ordre de
procéder à des interpellations
sur une vidéo il semble que l'on
aperçoit les deux personnes interpellées
je t'ai chacune un projectile sur les
forces de l'ordre
si ces faits étaient confirmés les
conditions pour procéder à leur
interpellation par être réunies reste à
déterminer
qui a donné l'ordre de procéder aux deux
interpellations vue
visible sur les vidéos pour quelles
raisons
des observateurs dont on sait désormais
qui ne sont pas membres des forces de
l'ordre ont ils pris une part active
dans l'interpellation de deux personnes
notamment en faisant usage de la force à
leur encontre
pour quelles raisons cet ordre n'at-il
pas été exécutée exclusivement par des
policiers voilà pour ce qui concerne les
questions sur les interpellations
deuxième série de questions que je me
poserai si j'étais saisi la
proportionnalité de l' usage de la force
les images vidéo pourrait laisser penser
que l'usagé de la force par les deux
observateurs au cours de leur
intervention n'est pas proportionnée au
comportement des deux personnes
interpellées au moment où ces gestes
sont pratiquées ces gestes ne sommes pas
correspondre aux gestes techniques
enseignées aux policiers c'est
l'expression qui est employé dans la
police de façon générale je toutes les
affaires comparables
le défenseur des droits après si la
proportionnalité de l' usage de la force
au regard notamment du but poursuivi
lors de l'intervention du contexte
l'intervention du comportement de la
personne appréhendée et des lésions
médicalement constatée après
l'intervention des éléments touchant à
la personne du réclamant tels que l'âge
ou l'état de santé entrent également en
ligne de compte
de même que les gestes techniques houle
armes utilisées ainsi parmi les
nombreuses affaires traitées en la
matière depuis sa création le défenseur
des droits a constaté un usage
disproportionné de la force et
recommander des sanctions disciplinaires
dans cette affaire s'étant déroulé dans
un contexte de maintien de l'ordre dans
trois affaires il s'agissait d'un usage
disproportionné de lanceurs de balles de
défense sur des manifestants alors que
les circonstances ne le
justifiait pas bien entendu je donnerais
autrement que verbalement toutes les
références de toutes les décisions dont
je parle bien entendu madame reporter
ces médiums comme vous savez tout est
sur mon site donc mais je vous donnerai
de référence possible une autre affaire
c'est l'utilisation de gaz lacrymogènes
sur des manifestants pacifiques
deux affaires concernent des coups
portés à des manifestants qui était déjà
maîtrisé et enfin c'est une affaire
d'ailleurs très récent que je viens de
passer devant le collège que préside
claudine angeli troccaz c'est à dire le
collège consultatif concernant la
déontologie de la sécurité
c'est une affaire qui concerne un
manifestant qui a été piétinée à
l'occasion de ce qu'on appelle
techniquement un bon offensif d'une
limité de de police
à ce point je sortirai simplement du des
constats que j'ai fait donc dans cette
affaire et et des interrogations qu'on
peut avoir sur la sphère qui vous
occupent pour me dire que il y aurait
probablement à réfléchir sur la
légitimité et l'intensité de l'usagé de
la force par les membres des forces de
sécurité
est ce que en quelque sorte
l'intensité est aujourd'hui accepter une
forte intensité est aujourd'hui accepter
davantage comme certains le disent est
ce qu'au contraire est-ce qu'on
contraire et notamment du fait de la
diffusion et on a là un exemple encore
dans notre affaire ici du fait de la
diffusion instantanée très large
des images prises par des observateurs
extérieurs de toute nature est ce qu'au
contraire il y a une plus grande
sensibilité à usage de la force
la question me paraît devoir à la fois à
l'occasion des opérations de maintien de
l'ordre mais aussi de manière générale
dans les interventions individuelles des
membres des forces sécurité
cette question me paraît devoir être
posée j'ai le pays 48 heures écouter
beaucoup des personnalités que vous avez
interrogé est certaine on te considérais
que l'intervention était proportionnée
d'autres au contraire que non nous nous
concertons que dans notre travail
quotidien
quand nous proposons par exemple une
sanction disciplinaire pour usage
disproportionné de la force
le plus souvent les autorités
hiérarchiques c'est à dire le ministre
de l'intérieur nous répond que ce n'est
pas ce qu'il a jugé et que donc il ne
donnera pas suite à notre demande de
sanction disciplinaire
voyez que cette appréciation elle me
paraît tout de même comment dirais-je
valoir une véritable interrogation à la
fois juridique et politique c'est ce que
je vous permet en tout cas de
de suggérer et pour ma part et pour
notre part je le dirai tout à l'heure
dans les travaux que nous avons faits
sur la doctrine de maintien de l'ordre
ce sont des questions que nous nous
sommes posée troisième point la réaction
des fonctionnaires de police lorsque les
observateurs font usage de la force
la réaction des policiers qui étaient
présents pendant que les observateurs
font usage de la force
évidemment poses différentes questions
que voit-il que font-ils quelles
instructions reçoivent t-il que saft il
à ce moment-là du statut des deux
observateurs il semble que les policiers
s'éloigne de l'action et qu'aucun agent
de la force publique ne s'interpose
lorsque monsieur ban à la maîtrise
violemment le jeune homme est ce que
c'est une question que nous nous posons
toujours dans nos instructions
est ce que les images vidéo donne ou pas
une vision exacte de la situation les
policiers pense-t-il avoir affaire à un
collègue koné style le statut des deux
observateurs les policiers pense-t-il
que l' usage de la force à l'encontre du
jeune homme et proportionnée ça revient
au débat que je disais tout à l'heure
sur la légitimité l'intensité d'usagé de
la force sur les différentes vidéos qui
circulent dans les médias
il sent que le policier référent chargé
de prendre en charge et deux
observateurs et régulièrement en retrait
de l'action il semble ne pas intervenir
pour expliquer aux observateurs le cadre
et les limites de leur présence ni
intervenir auprès des autres policiers
présents
quatrième point les suites données à ces
événements les policiers présents
ont-ils rédiger des rapports à l'issue
de leur mission comme c'est la norme
dans les réclamations traitées par le
défenseur des droits notamment sur les
violences dont ils ont été témoins et
qui ont fait l'objet de l'ouverture
d'une information judiciaire après la
diffusion de vidéos des vidéos sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est à dire après le 18
juillet
la hiérarchie des policiers informés
très rapidement après les faits grâce
aux vidéos circulant sur le réseau
sociaux at elle demandé des rapports
circonstanciés aux policiers qui sont
intervenus pour quelles raisons ces
faits vraisemblablement décrit dans des
rapports semblent ne pas avoir eu
immédiatement de suite ni judiciaire en
vertu de l'article 40 du code de
procédure pénale ni administrative avec
une saisine de l'igpn l'absence de
saisine de l'inspection générale dès le
1er mai s'explique-t-elle par le fait
que les observateurs ne sont pas
policiers ou parce que les réactions des
policiers visibles sur les vidéos ne
sont pas susceptibles de révéler des
manquements au regard des incertitudes
qui semblait exister sur le statut des
protagonistes et aussi sur les
responsabilités prises par les membres
de la hiérarchie policière
on pourrait s'interroger sur
l'éventualité d'une enquête immédiate de
l'igpn
enfin dernière question il semble que le
cnaps a délivré une habilitation à
monsieur benalla le 9 juillet 2018 pour
être dirigeant une entreprise de
sécurité privée
cette l'habilitation pourrait-elle été
remis en cause si l'effet du 1er mai ab
donné lieu à une enquête judiciaire ou
administrative permettez moi pour
conclure comme je l'aï dit tout à
l'heure j'ai le président madame et
monsieur le rapporteur de souhaiter que
la présente situation ne nuisent pas à
la pratique des observateurs car
l'observation extérieur et indépendante
est une garantie de transparence
indispensable au bon fonctionnement des
services publics et en particulier de
ceux qui sont chargés des missions
particulièrement difficile de la
sécurité et du maintien de l'ordre
c'est pour ça monsieur le président que
cela me conduit pour terminer à rappeler
quelles sont les préoccupations du
défenseur des droits
et les propositions des défenseurs des
droits
quant à la doctrine comme on dit du
maintien de l'ordre
vous savez que nous avions reçu au début
de 2010 est une demande d'étude de la
part du président assad nationale
monsieur claude bartolone et que j'ai
rendu cette étude au président de
l'assemblée nationale actuelle monsieur
françois de rugy en janvier 2018
cette étude dresse un bilan des outils
et des méthodes du maintien de l'ordre
au regard des règles de déontologie et
je me suis appuyé pour cela sur une
quarantaine de professionnels compétents
en la matière sur des éléments
comparatifs internationaux et enfin sur
les recommandations formulées à l'issue
du traitement de réclamations
individuelles et cette mission d'étude a
été conduite sous ma responsabilité par
claudine angélique troccaz je pense
qu'il serait souhaitable que les
recommandations issues de ce rapport
soit prise en compte dans le cadre des
travaux que mènent aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs la police nationale en vue de
faire évoluer la doctrine du maintien de
l'ordre
elle me semble pouvoir en tout cas vous
éclairer
pour ce qui vous concerne dans le cadre
de vos travaux trois principales
conclusions ou recommandations je
terminerais là dessus la gestion du
maintien de l'ordre doit reposer sur
l'emploi de forces professionnaliser et
formé comme les compagnies républicaines
de sécurité et la gendarmerie mobile
mais alors qu'aujourd'hui la pratique du
maintien de l'ordre est assez disparate
elle est disparate entre eux l'île de
france et les régions
elle est disparate entre les unités
constituées et spécialisés et celles qui
ne le sont pas je pense véritablement
que
tout milite en faveur de renforcement de
la formation et du contrôle des forces
chargées de l'ordre public
deuxième recommandation c'est celle qui
concerne et on en a souvent parlé
naturellement de l'usaj des multiples
armes de force intermédiaire donc
certaines faut bien le dire quoi peut
qualifier de non létales sont
susceptibles de faire des dégâts
absolument considérable y compris de
conduire à des décès nous sommes saisis
de plusieurs cas naturellement 2e
blessures graves ou de décès à la suite
d'utilisation
deux armes de force intermédiaire dans
des manifestations en particulier les
deux lanceurs de balles de défense lbd
40 46 et le flash-ball super pro au son
des armes qui provoque des dangers qui
sont souvent utilisés que sans respecter
toutes les règles d'emploi et je
rappelle que le flash ball par exemple
ne fait pas partie de la dotation des
gendarmes mobiles et qu'il a été retiré
de la dotation des policiers nationaux
ce qui montre que les objurgations du
défenseur des droits ont eu quelques
efficacité mais il fait encore partie de
la dotation d'autres unités de
gendarmerie qui sont susceptibles
d'intervenir en maintien de l'ordre en
renfort des gendarmes mobiles
j'ai donc recommandé que tous les
lanceurs de balles de défense soient
retirés de la dotation des forces de
sécurité qui interviennent en maintien
de l'ordre ne parle pas des
interventions individuelles
je parle du maintien de l'ordre et enfin
je voudrais dire que j'ai constaté
ce que l'on peut appeler une certaine
judiciarisation du maintien de l'ordre
ce qui me paraît soulever des
difficultés au regard de l' équilibre
entre les enjeux de sécurité
denis parent qui sont claires et la
protection des libertés publiques
j'ai donc recommandé de recentrer le
maintien de l'ordre sur la mission de
police administrative de prévention et
d'encadrement de l'exercice de la
liberté de manifester dans une approche
d'apaisement de désescalade
comme on dit aujourd'hui et de
protection des libertés individuelles
j'ai proposé de renforcer la
communication et le dialogue dans la
gestion de l'ordre public avant et
pendant le déroulement des
manifestations afin notamment de rendre
plus compréhensible l'action des forces
de sécurité et de favoriser la
concertation et enfants
j'ai proposé limiter le recours à
certaines techniques attentatoires aux
libertés tels que l'engagement les
contrôles délocaliser ce qui soulève à
nouveau naturellement la question plus
générale des contrôles d'identité et
d'autres pratiques mises en oeuvre dans
le cadre de l'état d'urgence les zones
de production protection les filtrages
gras voilà monsieur le président je
pensais que ouvrir la perspective de
l'ensemble des questions que peut poser
le maintien de l'ordre aujourd'hui peut
permettre à une haute assemblée
souvent à vide de réflexion en
profondeur
peut vous permettre de 2,2 de toucher du
doigt un certain nombre de sujets qui
sont à mon sens le contexte dans lequel
se situe une affaire que l'on peut
naturellement traiter de manière tout à
fait ponctuel est en tout cas une
information judiciaire est en train de
le faire bien entendu dans le cadre du
code pénal du code de procédure pénale
mais qui doit être aussi à mon avis
[Musique]
replacer dans la perspective d'un enjeu
très fort pour la démocratie
comment est ce que on assure la liberté
de manifester c'est à dire les libertés
publiques tout en garantissant la
sécurité des manifestants de ceux qui ne
manifestent pas et des forces de
sécurité et en respectant notamment pour
ces dernières les principes et les
règles de la déontologie de la sécurité
merci monsieur le défenseur des droits
pour ses propos liminaires qui ont
présenté la profondeur et la précision
qui caractérise vos vos propos lorsque
vous venez devant notre devant notre
commission certaines de vos questions
voire de vos réserves rejoignent
incontestablement nos préoccupations
rejoignent des nôtres vous avait dans un
premier temps rappelé un peu le cadre
général du contrôle qui est le veau de
la déontologie des forces de sécurité
d'après vous avez abordé plus
directement les questions qui sont à
l'origine un peu de notre commission
denquête qui veut essentiellement
vérifier enfin l'existence ou non de
dysfonctionnements qui ont conduit à la
situation et à l'émotion
que vous avez développé
j'ai noté d'ailleurs que vous avez accès
large partie de vos propos sur la
présence d'observateurs et sur la
question de savoir comment cette
présence qui est reconnue utile partout
au monde peut-être mieux encadrer en
tout cas mieux prévenu me circonscrite
et la commission on verra si la fin de
ces travaux il ya lieu sur ce point
d'effectuer ou non une recommandation
avec la puissance ou le degré de force
qui lui apparaîtra nécessaire monsieur
défenseur des droits nous allons
maintenant vous vous en doutez bien
aller plus précisément dans le coeur de
notre sujet et je vais vous donner la
parole à nos deux rapporteurs qui vous
poseront les questions qu'ils souhaitent
et éventuellement à celle de ceux qui
assistent à cette réunion pour alimenter
le débat sur ce point particulier alors
je donne la parole à notre collègue
chocolat pour les premières questions
dames la rapporteure merci le monsieur
président qu'il devient difficile de
vous poser une question désormais
néanmoins je vais me risquer elle n'est
pas si grande mais je vais me risquer en
risquant à la fois d'être d'être
redondant mais j'ai besoin d'avoir votre
avis
dans le cadre de vos compétences de
défenseur des droits sur une situation
qui nous a été exposé au cours de ses
auditions
vous savez vous l'avez dit qu'une vidéo
a été tournée à l'occasion des
manifestations du 1er mai qui a été mise
sur les réseaux sociaux très rapidement
dès le 2 mai est tout aussi rapidement a
été identifié sur cette vidéo
une personne qui interpellait des
individus au cours d'une manifestation
cette personne se révélant être un
observateur
monsieur b dallas pour le site et qui
donc intervenait au milieu des forces de
police dans le cadre d'une
interpellation que d'aucuns ont pu
qualifier d' un peu rugueuse et ne
maîtrisant pas ça aussi ça a été établie
vous l'avez rappelé des gestes
techniques de l'interpellation
cela a été révélé assez rapidement
notamment au ministère de l'intérieur
qu'il a su dès le 2 mai et qui donc
s'est rendu compte qu'il s'agissait d'un
observateur qui avait probablement mais
on le savait pas exactement où on en
connaissait pas les conditions échapper
à son référent puisque un observateur
même si les règles n'existent pas et
toujours dans la pratique accompagnée
d'un référent policiers qui est à la
fois chargé de sa protection mais aussi
de vérifier qu'il n'a pas de
comportement inapproprié
donc nous sommes dans cette situation
connue dès le 2 mai du ministère de
l'intérieur le ministère de l'intérieur
ne saisit pas l'igpn pour connaître
notamment les circonstances de ces actes
le 18 juillet une nouvelle vidéo et
médiatiser cette vidéo concerne la même
personne mais en des circonstances un
peu différente
de sorte qu apparaissent à l'écran des
éléments qui n'apparaissait pas à savoir
le fait que cet observateur monsieur b
dallas portaient un brassard de police
et avait également une radio sur
laquelle ils conversaient hélas le
ministère de l'intérieur saisi l'igpn
nous disons et c'est monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur qu'il a dit au
cours de son audition que le fait qu'on
découvre désormais le brassard de police
et la radio étaient des éléments
suffisants pour justifier la saisine de
l'igpn
ma question est la suivante estimez-vous
au regard de ces éléments que l'igpn
aurait dû être saisie dès le visionnage
de la première vidéo de l'interpellation
le 2 mai je lire monsieur le défenseur
des droits vous avez la parole bien sûr
pour répondre à cette question j'ajoute
une petite précision
c'est ces dalles lcd l'est ont fait
involontairement que les vidéos
la plupart des vidéos devait avoir
disparu puisque nous allons dépasser le
délai de 30 jours et que l'ensemble des
enregistrements qui ont pu être faits
par le réseau acropole ont disparu
puisque nous sommes après le délai de 60
jours maintenant le rapporteur quant à
la saisine de l'igpn
après la connaissance qu'on a eu des
événements et des personnes impliquées
dans ces événements par les vidéos je
distinguerai une saisine de l'igpn qui
serait ça s'appelait comme ça pour faire
une enquête administrative sur au moins
deux ministres team à ce moment là elle
pouvait porter sur les personnes qui
peut faire l'objet d'une à quatre
ministres et y est c'est à dire les
policiers mais elle ne pouvait pas
porter sur les personnes qui n'étaient
pas des policiers
et en l'occurrence sur les deux
observateurs première réponse
donc je dirais une ouverture de
l'enquêté administrative relativement
étroite ensuite ouverture d'une enquête
judiciaire dont l'igpn a le pouvoir le
pouvoir de faire là dessus
cette ouverture pouvait être justifiée
par la violence
les faits eux mêmes qui pouvait
naturellement être considéré comme
constitutif éventuellement d'infractions
pénales
sur ce point j'ai observé que la
directrice de l'inspection générale ce
matin lorsque vous l'avez entendu a
justement expliqué que cela n'ait pas
été fait parce que la force qui avait
été employé les gestes qu'ils avaient
été faits avaient été considérés comme
proportionnée en quelque sorte oui ou
non violent ou pas suffisamment violent
pour entraîner 7e
l'ouverture de cette enquête et c'est un
peu à partir de cette réflexion qui a
été faite ce matin par un bonnet g du
sorbet que je vous ai posé tout à
l'heure la question de légitimité
intensité de l'usagé de la force par les
forces de sécurité est une question qui
mérite d'être posée
suivant les points de vue que l'on a
donc sur l' enquête administrative comme
sur l' enquête judiciaire voilà le
positionnement de la question et je vous
ai dit tout à l'heure je veux dit tout à
l'heure que de mon point de vue la
question pouvait vraiment se poser au
moment des faits puisque vous avez bien
parler de du 2 mai d'ouvrir en tout cas
eu une enquête judiciaire
mais je me garderai bien
le rapporteur de vous donner là dessus
une opinion du défenseur des droits
parce que je n'ai naturellement aucun
titre le faire mais ça fait partie des
questions qui méritent d'être posées
même la porte vous voulez précisé
peut-être votre question oui j'avais
d'autres jeux non pas du tout je prends
note de la réponse de monsieur le
défenseur droit je l'en remercie ma
question réalité ne portait pas tant sur
l'igpn elle même car il nous est
expliqué ce matin qu'ils ignoraient
totalement qu'il s'agissait d'un
observateur il pensait qu'il s'agissait
d'un policier ce qui permet
effectivement de considérer les choses
différemment ce qu'il portait sur le
fait que les personnes qui avait la
connaissance de la qualité
d'observateurs c'est à dire du fait que
nous étions totalement hors d'une
interpellation normal aurait pu
s'interroger et peut-être se répondent
favorablement sur la saisine asmodee
giped voir l' usage de l'article car
effectivement à deux questions que les
bucs qu'on saisisse igpn ou plus gpn se
se saisissent pas cessé c'est bon mais
mais là même le rapporteur permettez moi
de vous dire que votre commission
denquête il parviendra peut-être mais
moi je serai bien impuissant à sonder
les reins et les coeurs de ceux ou de
celles dont vous parlez merci beaucoup
mam leurs portes voulez vous poser une
autre question maintenant attendre
éventuellement vous renoncez poser des
questions
sa commission denquête s'applique à moi
quasiment pour l'instant je cède mon
tour à ceux qui veulent poser des
questions alors vous cédez
nécessairement votre tour à un autre
collègue jean-pierre sueur
merci monsieur le président
donc en ma qualité de co rapporteurs
puisque nous sommes deux monsieur toubon
défenseur des droits je voulais d'abord
vous dire que votre discours liminaire
extrêmement élaboré sera précieux car
vous en tendant je me disais qu'on
pourrait presque réfléchir à une
proposition de loi qui permettrait eux
d'appréhender toutes ces situations
d'observateurs lors diverses actions
relatives à la sécurité ou d'autres
parce que c'est vrai que le statut est
assez floue nous avons eu nous avons eu
beaucoup de mal à savoir qui était à
l'origine de la décision de faire que
monsieur ben ben alla peut soit rapport
soir à porter soit observateurs excusez
moi à la journée longue soit
observateurs un et nous avons eu
quelques peines à bien comprendre qui
dans la police était tuteur s'il y avait
un tuteur est donc chargé de
l'accompagner voire de rendre compte de
ce qui s'est passé puisque une des
questions vous l'avez peut-être vu que
nous avons eu l'honneur de poser à
monsieur le préfet de police est la
suivante
finalement dans cette affaire le préfet
de police de paris
comme le ministre de l'intérieur ont été
informés des faits par l'elysée mais pas
par quelqu'un de la police nationale or
compte tenu de la gravité des faits il
eût été quand même évident que
le responsable de la sécurité publique
sur place rendre compte de ce qui s'est
passé au préfet de police et au
ministère de l'intérieur
alors donc merci pour cet apport qui
pourra je crois donné lieu à des travaux
utiles
j'ai deux questions la première sur la
question de l'article 40 je crois que
ceux qui avaient déjà un article 40 à
ses célèbres dans la sphère
parlementaire qui nous fait de réagir
très souvent oui et alors nous avons
maintenant nul n'ignore dans la
république française
l'article 40 du code de procédure pénale
qui dit que toute autorité constituée et
cetera et cetera qui a connaissance d'un
délit ou d'un crime est nu en informer
le procureur de la république sans délai
à cet égard nous avons posée à monsieur
le ministre de l'intérieur la question
de savoir pourquoi il n'avait pas
appliqué l'article 40 parce que lorsque
la vidéo apparaît il est clair qu'il ya
un membre du cabinet du président de la
république qui fait usage de force une
force policière alors qu'il n'est pas
policier et qu'il n'a aucun titre à le
faire qui de plus s'arroge des signes
distinctifs de la police nationale alors
qu'il a aucun chiffre à l'envers
monsieur le ministre l'intérieur tous a
dit hé monsieur le préfet de police nous
a dit dès lors que l'élysée saisie et
c'est vrai que l'elysée était saisie
puisque c'est l'elysée qui les a saisies
l'un et l'autre il revenait au directeur
de cabinet du président de la république
au secrétaire-général et pourquoi pas au
président de la république lui-même de
saisir la justice
et alors tout le monde se renvoie le
la chose et personne n'a en définitive
appliquer cet article donc je voulais
savoir qu'elle est en tant que défenseur
des droits votre appréciation sur le
fait que tout le monde se dérobe alors
qu'il y ait un délit qui est patent
devant l'application de l'article 40 il
est vrai que cet article 40 ne comporte
pas de sanction quand il n'est pas
appliquée c'est la première question je
sais pas si je pose la deuxième si vous
voulez monsieur le défenseur des droits
est très très complets tout à l'heure où
la boule au nom alors je peux m'imposer
la lauzière des également que l'arrêt
pour les connaisseurs y aura est il fera
une réponse globale ne en deuxième dieu
e on se pose tous la question imaginons
dans les diverses responsabilités que
nous sommes plus exercer des salles des
autres quelqu'un qui dysfonctionnent
aussi gravement
il est quand même indispensable qui est
pour le moins à une sanction
monsieur le directeur de cabinet me met
en oeuvre une sanction
et il met à pied la personne pendant
quinze jours il le prive de son salaire
dans des mots dans des conditions
d'application qui n'ont plus donné lieu
à quelques débats et après il revient
mais moi j'ai un réflexe un peu
peut-être instinctif monsieur le et
peut-être trop une personne comme ça moi
si j'étais le patron
j'aurais plutôt comme idée de
l'exfiltrer totalement et de faire que
si au bout des 15 jours de mise à pied
garde son emploi de le mettre dans un
service administratif par exemple aux
archives ou dans d'autres services non
pas dans un placard car j'ai toujours
été non madame benbassa j'ai toujours
été opposé à tout tout placardisation
parce que
c'est une manière de se moquer des gens
et de mépriser ce que tout être humain
peut apporter aux services publics mais
en tout cas de ne pas le mettre
après de ne pas le placer en première
ligne dans des matières qui ont trait à
la sécurité et à la protection
d'ailleurs monsieur le porte-parole de
l'elysée dit qu'après sa mise à pied
il a été déchargé des questions de
protection de sécurité
mais alors après nous avons demandé à
monsieur directeur de cabinet
comment ça s'est traduit peut-être parce
que je le lien sur arrivée autre
question mais j'arrive la question
comment comment ça s'est traduit et bien
ça s'est traduit par le fait que ledit
personnage
naturellement il n'était pas responsable
de la sécurité de la protection il
continuer à s'occuper des déplacements
privés du président de la république et
pour ce qui est de la vie publique
il apparaissait dans des fonctions tout
à fait officiel qu'il s'agisse
d'accueillir à roissy les bleus et de le
transporter il était dans le bus avec
les joueurs les footballeur et
d'ailleurs il a demandé que le bus aille
plus vite devenir respecter l'horaire
alors que des gens étaient là monsieur
le président depuis quatre heures en
train de l'attendre il a s'est occupé du
14 juillet il s'est occupé de simone
veil les de l'entrée au panthéon de
descendre aussi mollet
donc on peut perdre one dont on peut se
dire quand même qu'il y à eu
maldonne au sens où on a le sentiment qu
après comme avant ils étaient
pratiquement dans des fonctions
analogues
est ce que cela est ce que ça vous
paraît conforme au droit
vous qui êtes le défenseur des droits
premièrement que personne ne sait si ce
n'utilise l'article 40
deuxièmement qu'après la mise à pied la
personne retrouve ses fonctions le
précité
voilà merci beaucoup de cette notion
encore à la retraite
je vais prendre est d'abord monsieur le
co rapporteur sur la deuxième question
moi je ne peux dans ce genre de
situation que proposer des solutions de
droit et quand j'ai dit les solutions de
droit je veux dire des solutions qui
soit respectueuse du droit et des droits
y compris des droits de la personne
concernée naturellement et que en
quelque sorte
en vertu de ces principes
je récuse ce qui est souvent pratiqué ce
que j'appellerai les solutions ou les
formules dissimulé il me paraît que de
manière générale et nous avons par
exemple dans des réclamations pourtant
sur les sujets de discrimination nous
avons des cas où nous voyons par exemple
des personnes qui
vont être discriminée par exemple parce
que on va leur confier des fonctions ou
des dossiers qui sont considérés comme
péjoratif ou inférieur ce n'est pas une
vraie sanction mais nous l'analysons et
notamment lorsque ça s'applique à des
personnes en raison de leur santé de
leur âge de leur handicap de leur
grossesse l'orientation sexuelle nous
l'analysons comme une discrimination
donc je vous répondrai simplement que je
ne peux pas naturellement juger de ce
que vous avez dit sur le cas de la
personne qui fait l'objet de la
commission denquête mais je peux dire
que si après la règle de droit est bien
appliquée c'est correct
si ce n'est pas le cas ce n'est pas
correct et ce que je crois c'est que
dans ces affaires-là bruce avait le
droit du travail surtout s'agissant
d'une personne qui était à près d'après
ce que je comprends contractuel donc le
droit du travail est pleinement
applicable sur la première question
c'est à dire sur l'application de
l'article quand je vais vous répondre et
je dirais à la commission et à tous ceux
qui sont présents ici ou qui nous
regardent nous écoute
entendez bien ma réponse est pour ce
qu'elle est
terre ma réponse sera tout entière
fondée sur l'indépendance et
l'impartialité qui constitue la
substance même du statut du défenseur
des droits
si j'avais été saisis dans ma mission de
contrôle de la déontologie de la
sécurité
j'aurais agi comme je lai déjà fait dans
un cas
que j'ai eu à connaître à l'occasion des
manifestement des manifestations contre
la loi travail du printemps 2016 par ma
décision
2010cette 320 du 1er décembre 2017
j'ai signalé les faits au parquet de la
même façon
j'aurais pu le faire dans la présente
circonstances mais mais je ne suis pas
devant vous mais je co rapporteurs dames
et messieurs comme simple citoyen comme
anciens collègues parlementaires de
longue date comme ancien garde des
sceaux ce soit d'autre
vous m'entendez en tant que défenseur
des droits et en cette qualité
je n'ai pas a exprimé d'opinion
j'accomplis une mission
constitutionnelle et en l'occurrence je
n'ai pas eu à le faire quand réponse
était très clair monsieur défenseur des
droits je vais passer la parole
maintenant à notre collègue esther
benbassa je trouverais il légitime
inéquitable que vous n'ayez qu'une
minute pour votre question donc vous en
avez deux sinon su études
quelle mention merci monsieur le
président d'abord je voudrais vers une
petite rectification il n'y a pas eu de
suspension de traitement pendant la mise
à pied de monsieur benalla mais une
future retenus sur ses congés payés en
retard
ouais ouais voilà écoutez maintenant je
reviens
la question un peu plus importante c'est
important quand même cette rectification
je voulais savoir monsieur le défenseur
des droits si vous avez déjà eu des
remontées d'incidents liés à ce genre
d'observateurs agissant lors de
manifestations parallèlement aux côtés
de forces de l'ordre ou parallèlement
aux gendarmes etc
deuxième question est ce que ce jour-là
à la contrescarpe sur la place est-ce
que l'intervention des crs était
justifiée puisqu'il s'agissait paraît-il
à je ne connais pas tous les détails
paraît-il d'un apéro festif et si je me
réfère à ce qu'a dit la directrice de
l'igpn
il s'agissait des gestes techniques mal
maîtrisées et sans préjudice corporel et
monsieur strauss d'un a dit inapte à
faire
il a il n'a pas relevé et d'acharnement
entre le monsieur entre le monsieur
benalla et les personnes qu'il frappait
alors peut-être que vous avez plus de
détails et puis vous avez parlé du fait
que monsieur benalla avait un agrément
n'est ce pas que je me suis trompé
un agrément pour créer sa boîte privée
c'est une nouveauté enfin pour nous pour
nous aujourd'hui on n'a pas entendu
peut-être je me suis trompé une année
une habilitation comme agent de sécurité
privé une habilitation là et que c'était
une fille habilitation qui auraient été
donnés et c'est dans une des auditions
d'ailleurs que vous avez fait ici que ça
a été dit qui auraient été donnés en
2014 pour expirer ce que c'est des
habilitations de cinq ans en 2019
voilà une habilitation donc comme agent
de sécurité privé est la question que
j'ai posée
c'était justement
que j'ai posée d'emblée c'était de
savoir si l'activité qu'exercer monsieur
bénard était effectivement celle d'un
agent de sécurité privé auquel cas par
hypothèse jours et était compétent comme
défenseur des droits parce que je suis
compétent voilà mais c'est la seule
question que je posais et elle est
purement hypothétique et en en ce qui
concerne le premièrement nous n'avons
pas eu de cas où nous avons eu à mettre
en cause en réalité pour leur
comportement des observateurs en
revanche nous avons eu souvent deux fois
des cas où les observateurs au sens
général pouvait se trouver victimes en
quelque sorte des agissements de la
police doivent rendre y est donc venir
réclamer chez nous par exemple
c'est le cas de journalistes qui peuvent
avoir été pris à partie ou qui peuvent
avoir été blessé c'est le cas aussi d'un
certain nombre de personnes qui
pouvaient se trouver d'un mètre donc
donc oui nous avons eu à traiter de cas
d'observateurs mais non pas du tout
comme éventuels auteurs de manquement
contraire aux règles de déontologie mais
au contraire comme victimes de ces
éventuels eu manquement je ne peux pas
naturellement vous dire exactement ce
qu'il en est et vous avez fait allusion
la déposition du directeur de cabinet du
président à public de la directrice du
de l'inspection générale de la police
nationale de ce qu'il en était de la
manifestation qui se déroulait place de
la poudre à ce cap
jour bien simplement sur ce que j'ai dit
déjà deux reprises il y a une vraie
question d'appréciation de ce qu'est l'
usage de la force et à quel degré usage
de la force en quelque sorte est
admissible ou pas admissible et on voit
bien que pour certains cette
admissibilité et à ses hôtes et pour
d'autres elle est beaucoup plus basse et
j'ajoute même ça que je pense que c'est
peut-être une des questions que dans
l'information judiciaire les magistrats
auront seront amenés à élucider puisque
il est clair qu'un des quatre chefs de
2,2 d'accusation de ces se porte sur
justement
effectivement les violences qui ont été
exercées et est-ce qu'elles sont de
nature à être qualifiés pénalement
donc attendons là dessus que les juges
fassent leur travail
merci beaucoup le défenseur des droits
une nouvelle fois et en raison même de
l'attachement au sénat et en particulier
comme s'ils ont des lois vous vouliez
poser une question ah mais c'est
toujours poussier allez-y une question
très très courte vous nous avez parlé de
d'éléments distinctifs qui permet de
distinguer un observateur d'un policier
en mission et en exercice et vous nous
avez montré ce magnifique brassard aux
vues aux vues non mais au moins par aux
vêtements artisanat non mais
parfaitement lisible en tout cas est a
priori pas remis dans les auditions
qu'on a eu c'est le premier élément
qu'on a deux
d'un élément distinctif est ce que votre
connaissance vous avez vous connaissez
d'autres d'autres
élément distinctif puisque je suis là
c'est vraiment celui qui est attribué au
défenseur de représentants des
défenseurs des droits est ce que parce
que d'après les auditions nous on a
retenu simplement que les observateurs
étaient dotés d'un casque de protection
ce qu'on peut imaginer éventuellement
d'un gilet pare balles et puis c'est
tout mais cette région connaît au moins
deux d'abord évidemment la presse qui
est toujours affublée de si distinctif y
compris oui mais c'est là où je rejoins
ce qu'il vient de dire tout à l'heure le
président sur établir une réglementation
sur les observateurs les référents et
herat est indispensable je crois qu'il
faut sortir de ce fou mais en même temps
mais en même temps ce sera très
difficile car l'observation comprend
naturellement par exemple le travail de
la presse qui ne peut pas être encadrés
sauf à mettre en cause la liberté de 2,2
de cette dernière
donc je dirais que un journaliste alors
vous savez très bien que de toute façon
il ya des systèmes d'accréditation de la
presse
mais si j'ose dire un journaliste n'a
jamais à demander l'autorisation pour
faire son métier
bien entendu donc je pense que il ya
donc les journalistes qui ont
effectivement la presse
mais il ya aussi il ya aussi dans
certaines circonstances ce que
j'appellerais des ong des associations
notamment celle qui s'occupe de
questions humanitaires ou de questions
médicales par exemple et qui sont sur
les lieux et qui eux soit on qu'une
mission précise par exemple pour
certaines la prise en charge sanitaire
par exemple mais d'autres sont
simplement là comme observateur et elles
peuvent à ce moment là être
effectivement de manière très lisible
distingué avec un brassard avec le
la dénomination de l'organisation par
exemple c'est donc donc je crois que de
ce point de vue de ce point de vue à mon
avis le les exigences minimum du statut
d'observateur pourrait être relativement
facile à établir si vous pensez que ce
serait opportun
merci beaucoup pour cette dernière
précision je reviens sur les
remerciements que j'allais vous propos
prononcés tout à l'heure c'est toujours
d'un grand intérêt pour nous monsieur
défenseur des droits de deux de vous
entendre particulier au sénat en
particulier la commission des lois vous
connaissez notre attachement à la
défense des devoirs aux droits
fondamentaux et aux libertés
fondamentales
c'est donc encore une fois une audition
qui n'avait permis ce qui a été très
très intéressant maintenant libertés
fondamentales ce qui est la mission que
la constitution l'article 51 m'a convié
m'a confié ça consiste entre autres à
aider la représentation nationale
elle-même à défendre les droits les
libertés fondamentales